how do you think being here at skankfest
differs from your just regular tour life
as far as interacting with the fans
after your shows well I sell all my own
merch after shows still and people are
very nice there and they're very nice
here the only thing here is like walking
around is difficult cuz like guys come
up and they're like hey this is my wife
she's got huge tits cuz like I have a
podcast called chubby Behemoth and one
of the initial bits that hit was like
who's got him talking about women's
heavy breasts so now dudes come up after
the show with a girl who's like been
dragged to the show begrudgingly and
they're like this is the guy that I
listen to all day on the you
know I'm driving my forklift she's got
him and then he like gra reaches over
and like lifts up her boob and it's like
I have not said a word to your wife yet
this is horrific this is like the worst
intro to meeting someone ever you're
just like that happens up there that's
happened like eight times today that's
someone coming up and being like I love
the Pod dude check these out and it's
like no that's a comedic Persona like I
would never objectify a woman on the
street she isn't wearing a bra and then
it's game on